which of the following is a correct
interpretation of the expression
positive equation is a one plus six well
before I even read this let's just think
about what's happening when one plus six
on the number line I'm going to start at
one which is going to be one to the
right of zero and then I'm going to add
another six so I'm going to go six more
to the right of zero to end up at seven
which is going to be seven to the right
of zero the number that is six to the
left of one on the number line now six
to the left of one in this type of a
number line which is the standard number
line where to the right is positive and
to the left is negative if you move six
to the left that means you're
subtracting 6 from one so that's not
right we're adding six the number that
is six to the right of one on the number
line yeah that's exactly right we're
going we're going 6 to the right if
you're adding six you're moving to the
right you're going to increase so that's
definitely going to be the choice let's
keep going which of the following is a
correct interpretation of the expression
three plus negative seven so one before
I even look at these choices one way I
would think about it is I would start at
three and then I would move seven to the
left of three I'm adding negative seven
so this is the same thing as 3 minus 7
so it moves seven to the left of three
so let's see what Davers say start at
seven on the number line and move three
to the left no that doesn't make sense I
want to start at three if you'll just
skip over here start at 3 on the number
line and move seven to the left yeah
that's exactly right we're going to
start at three and we're going to move
seven in the negative direction into the
left if if our convention which is our
standard convention that to the left is
negative and to the right is more
positive so that's going to be exactly
right
let's do one more so now they have three
minus negative four well one way to
think about it one way to think about it
is three minus negative four is the same
thing if you subtract a negative it's
the same thing as adding the positive
version so the same thing as three plus
four and so I would want to start at
three and then move four to the right
because once again this is this is the
same thing as 3 plus 4 3 minus negative
4 is the same thing as 3 plus 4
so I want to start at 3 and move four to
the right start at three and move four
to the right this would be the same
thing as three plus four which is the
same thing as that expression